let's go instead to tyler from australia
tyler from australia you were on the air
what's going on there
hi david how you doing good how are you
i'm doing great
um earlier today on twitter i saw a
picture of
a u.s flat with 52 stars and
now that the dems have the senate the
house and the presidency
i was wondering what your opinion is or
if you think it's possible that we could
have maybe one
or two more states given statehood
it would be absolutely fantastic i am
very significantly supportive of it
i think dc as a democratic state is
obvious because it's so overwhelmingly
democratic
i actually think it's a little less
clear in
in terms of puerto rico because there is
actually a
a a a more conservative contingent there
and if puerto rico were to become a
state i think you would see republicans
pour in resources to try to get a
senator there
um so i think that it on balance
dc plus puerto rico is absolutely good
for democrats i think
if you're assuming it would be all uh
democrats
you you may be wrong but i would be
hugely supportive of that and i would
love to see democrats
in control of the house senate and the
white house take that up and look at
making that a reality
yeah i was pretty much certain that the
dc area would
go heavily towards the democrats but
right i was a bit more worried about the
puerto rico area because
it's like a bit more of that latina vote
and
yeah but remember the latino vote the
latino vote is very left other than
cuban americans but
that can still mean you have 35 percent
38 percent 41 percent that would still
be i don't know exactly what the numbers
are in puerto rico
you still end up with some republican
members of congress and maybe even
a senator depending on who chooses to
vote with those numbers it's just less
overwhelming in puerto rico
yeah right so it could even balance out
with just like a one for one
i don't think it would i think i think
it would lean blue but it's just not
there's some people who are like this
it'll be all democrats and i think that
that's probably not true
yeah all right well thank you very much
all right my pleasure great to uh great
to hear from you